Bonsoir
Ce soir on va parler du phénomène Zemmour,
nouveau Poujade ou "Donald Trump de France"
comme certains médias étrangers le perçoivent...
À quatre mois de la présidentielle,
la popularité de ce polémiste ne cesse de grimper.
Selon les derniers sondages,
il est crédité de 17% d'intentions de vote.
On va essayer de comprendre
comment un barbouilleur
qui défrayait la chronique par ses propos racistes,
misogynes,
un histrion sans programme, ni parti politique,
a-t-il pu acquérir une telle audience politique ?
Pour élucider le phénomène Zemmour
on va s'appuyer sur un livre de l'historien français Gérard Noiriel,
auteur de nombreux ouvrages
sur l'histoire de l'immigration en France
dont :
Une histoire populaire de la France
et Les ouvriers dans la société française XIX -ème- XX -ème siècle.
Le livre en question de Noiriel paru chez la Découverte
est intitulé,
"Le venin dans la plume- Édouard Drumont, Éric Zemmour, et la part sombre de la République."
Gérard Noiriel compare la trajectoire d'Édouard Drumont,
le père de l'antisémitisme à la française
à la fin du XIX -ème siècle
et auteur du best-seller "La France juive ",
et Éric Zemmour,
figure de proue de l'islamophobie
et auteur d'un autre best-seller, « Le suicide français".
À la fin de 19-ème siècle
Drumont s'en prenait aux juifs
En ce début du 21ème siècle
Zemmour s'en prend aux musulmans.
Cent trente années séparent Éric Zemmour d’Édouard Drumont,
mais un même langage les réunit,
celui de la haine.
Une haine simpliste et terrible :
pour Drumont tout juif est un Rothschild
et pour Zemmour tout musulman est un Ben Laden.
Les deux hommes utilisent la même prose identitaire,
qui prend pour cible un ennemi intérieur
œuvrant au déclin de la France
avec la complicité des élites françaises.
Les deux polémistes prétendent être les porte-voix des petits,
des sans grades
spolié par la finance juive selon Drumont,
menacés de disparition par la déferlante musulmane selon Zemmour.
Ecoutez Zemmour parle de l’Islam et des musulmans
Ils sont voleurs… ils sont assassins… ils sont violeurs…
Gérard Noiriel met en parallèle
les idées de Drumont et celles de Zemmour
pour montrer que l'antisémitisme de l'un
et l'islamophobie de l'autre
sont issus de la même matrice discursive.
Drumont et Zemmour essaient de récrire une histoire identitaire de la France
sur un mode tragique,
scandée par l’affrontement récurrent
entre la France éternelle
et deux figures interchangeables.
Chez Drumont, le juif voilà l’ennemi !
Le sémite vs l'Aryen.
Chez Zemmour
c'est le musulman opposé au blanc catholique.
Gérard Noiriel note que les deux pamphlétaires
affectionnent la métaphore du démembrement,
annonciateur de la fin de la nation française.
Les deux se réfèrent au même « précédent » historique,
celui de la Pologne.
S’attaquant à Émile Zola durant l’affaire Dreyfus,
Drumont écrit :
" Il trouve, en un mot, en l'occurrence le mot   J'accuse,
que le moment est venu de supprimer la France
comme on a supprimé la Pologne".
Zemmour reprend en écho dans son livre Destin français (p. 190),
il dit :
"La monarchie absolue fut le seul moyen
que les grands serviteurs de la France aient trouvé
pour éviter à notre pays le sort funeste de la Pologne"
Les deux polémistes s'accordent sur un point essentiel :
Que la religion catholique est le fondement de l'identité française
Selon Drumont, le catholicisme est l'âme de la nation française
et Zemmour se dit :
" convaincu qu'on ne peut être français
sans être profondément imprégné du catholicisme"
(Destin français p. 28).
Souvent dans son récit identitaire,
Zemmour parle de civilisation chrétienne et non judéo-chrétienne,
sans doute pour occulter ses origines juives
et revendiquer une assimilation totale dans la civilisation chrétienne
et en particulier dans le catholicisme.
Toujours dans son livre Destin français (p. 307),
évoquant la guerre civile de Vendée pendant la Révolution française,
il écrit :
" Aujourd'hui, nous sommes tous des catholiques vendéens"
Le jeune historien français Joel Sebban,
auteur d'un livre remarquable, intitulé :
"Le mythe de la civilisation Judéo-chrétienne"
pense que Zemmour
fait partie d'un courant assimilationniste minoritaire
dans la communauté juive de France au 19 -ème siècle
qui cultivait une admiration paradoxale pour Maurice Barrès,
figure notoire de l’antisémitisme.
Ce même Maurice Barrès, auteur de la Terre et les morts,
dont s’inspire aujourd’hui Éric Zemmour.
Comme Drumont et Barrès,
Zemmour s'en prend aux élites politiques et intellectuelles françaises,
qu’il désigne comme "le parti de l'étranger".
Il écrit dans son Suicide français (p. 10) :
" Notre passion immodérée pour la Révolution
nous a aveuglés et pervertis,
en nous faisant oublier les mille ans d'histoire
qui l'avaient précédée".
Il pense que Les philosophes des Lumières,
dont les idées ont imprégné la Révolution française,
sont responsables de cet humanisme funeste
qui est en train de perdre la France.
Zemmour cible Voltaire en particulier
qui le considère comme
« le père des générations successives
de destructeurs, déconstructeurs, nihilistes, amoureux insatiables de la table rase".
Zemmour comme Drumont déteste Victor Hugo,
et le considère comme le grand responsable de l’humanisme compassionnel,
si prompt à prendre parti pour les criminels contre les honnêtes gens.
Dans son roman Les Misérables,
n’a-t-il pas fait de l'ignoble Jean Valjean son héros.
Les deux auteurs, partagent la même haine de la justice républicaine
et des juges qui se sont selon eux convertis à la religion des droits de l'homme.
Je vous lis un passage (Page 125)
de dernier livre de Zemmour
"La France n'a pas dit son dernier mot",
un mélange de mépris de la justice et de misogynie abjecte.
Après son procès
pour diffamation et provocation à la haine raciale en janvier 2011,
il s’en prend ainsi à la présidente du tribunal,
à la procureure et aux avocates.
Il dit :
"Le président du tribunal est une femme,
le procureur également.
La plupart des avocats de mes accusateurs aussi.
Sous leur robe noire en guise d’uniforme prestigieux d’une autre époque,
elles portent des vêtements de médiocre qualité à l’étoffe fatiguée,
sont coiffées à la hâte,
maquillées sans soin ;
tout dans leur silhouette,
dans leurs attitudes,
leur absence d’élégance,
dégage un je-ne-sais-quoi de négligé,
de laisser-aller,
de manque de goût.
On voit au premier coup d’œil
que ces métiers
– effet ou cause de la féminisation –
ont dégringolé les barreaux de l’échelle sociale.
Il flotte une complicité entre elles, proximité de sexe et de classe."
Madame Zemmour est pourtant avocate
et sa principale conseillère mademoiselle Sarah Knafo est magistrate.
Voilà qui ne manque pas de Piquant !!
Drumont et Zemmour dénoncent tous les deux
les destructeurs de la famille française.
Le premier accuse les juifs
d'être à l'origine de la loi du 27 juillet 1884
rétablissant le divorce,
loi adoptée sur proposition du député Alfred Naquet.
Il écrit :
" Le juif Naquet a réussi à imposer de toute force
à cette France qui a dû si longtemps sa grandeur morale
à son respect pour l'indissolubilité du mariage",
la France juive (tome 2, p. 272).
Quant à Éric Zemmour,
, il accuse le lobby homosexuel - ce monstre enfanté par Mai 68 -
d'œuvrer en sous-main à la liquidation de l'ordre familial.
Il dit dans son " Destin français, p. 499 :
« La mort du patriarcat du petit mâle blanc hétérosexuel occidental
signe la mort de l'Occident ».
Sur la même lancée,
Zemmour s'attaque à deux figures
qui ont joué un rôle important
dans la lutte pour l'émancipation des femmes.
D’abord, Simone de Beauvoir
l'auteur du "Deuxième Sexe",
qui a dit "on ne naît pas femme, on le devient"
et qui est selon Zemmour la pionnière de la théorie du genre
et Simone Veil,
l'ancienne ministre de la Santé
parce qu'elle a été à l'origine de la loi
autorisant les interruptions volontaires de grossesse (IVG)
adoptée le 17 janvier 1975.
Zemmour estime dans son livre, Le suicide français,
qu’à partir de ce moment-là,
" La famille traditionnelle de souche française
doit s'incliner au nom du progrès sous la pression individualiste.
Dans le même temps
- comme pour compenser symboliquement et démographiquement-
la famille maghrébine la plus traditionnelle,
la plus archaïques,
la plus patriarcale-
est invitée à prendre la relève".
L'obsession migratoire,
poussera Zemmour
à reprendre à son compte la thèse complotiste du grand remplacement,
une théorie raciste et xénophobe
réintroduite en 2010 par l'écrivain d’extrême droite Renaud Camus.
Zemmour affirme qu'une ville comme Montreuil
est désormais sous transfusion malienne
et que les banlieues sont déjà presque totalement islamisées.
L'historien Gérard Noiriel
a déniché des propos de la même veine chez Édouard Drumont,
sauf que pour Drumont les envahisseurs ne sont pas les musulmans
mais plutôt les juifs
Il écrit dans son livre la France juive (tome 1 p. 322) :
" On constate,  que dans le département de la Seine
la présence de 2733 israélite,
on voit à quel point ils ont multiplié
puisque quelques chiffres du Consistoire
permettent d'en compter environ 42000 avérés."
" Drumont affirme que les juifs ont établi leur quartier général à Nancy,
qui est devenue une" petite Jérusalem".
Et d’ajouter :
" La religion n'est ordinairement relative qu'aux choses qui intéressent la conscience,
alors que chez les juifs
la religion embrasse tout ce qui fonde et régit la société (…).
Les juifs forment partout une nation dans la nation,
ils ne sont ni Français,
ni Allemands,
ni Anglais,
ni Prussiens,
ils sont juifs"
(La France juive, tome 1, p. 312.).
Cent trente ans après,
Éric Zemmour martèle à longueur de pages:
" L'islam est à la fois une identité, une religion, et un système juridico-politique...
Musulman signifie en arabe :
soumis à Dieu ;
l'individu est donc soumis à la Communauté des croyants : l'Oumma.
Cette nation musulmane s'impose à l'individu,
mais aussi aux nations où le musulman pourrait être appelé à séjourner"
(Destin français, p. 552 ; Le suicide français, p. 478 et p. 145).
La similitude du « raisonnement » est frappante !
! Même si la raison n’a rien à voir avec ce délire.
Le deux libellistes Drumont et Zemmour
partagent une vision misogyne du monde,
et un mépris sans équivoque pour les femmes.
Drumont disait,
péremptoire :
" Aux époques de décadence,
on l'a constaté,
la femme monte tandis que l'homme descend".
Admirons maintenant les perles de son disciple Zemmour.
Parlant de l'attraction des femmes par les hommes de pouvoir,
il dit dans son dernier livre
La France n'a pas dit son dernier mot p, 61:
"Les histoires de fesses
ont toujours distrait toutes les campagnes présidentielles.
Celles-ci sont habituellement le cadre de grands élans et de menus plaisirs.
Les candidats sont en transe
lorsqu’ils fendent la foule des meetings
ou descendent de la tribune sous les acclamations ;
les femmes sont attirées comme des aimants
par ces ‘bêtes politiques’."
Écoutez Zemmour,
explique le lien entre la virilité masculine et le pouvoir.
Dans ce même livre
Eric Zemmour
prend bec et ongles la défense de deux hommes accusés de viol,
l'ancien patron du FMI Dominique Strauss-Kahn
et, curieusement, l'islamiste Tariq Ramadan.
A propos du premier, il dit page 139 :
"DSK, menottes derrière le dos entre deux cops
(c'est-à-dire deux policiers) new-yorkais,
marchant tête baissée,
c’est un renversement de mille ans de culture royale et patriarcale française.
C’est une castration de tous les hommes français.
Le séducteur est devenu un violeur,
le conquérant un coupable.
‘L’homme à femmes’ était loué pour sa force protectrice,
il est enfermé et vitupéré pour sa violence intempérante.
Don Juan est mort.
Comme disait Philippe Murray,
‘on est passé de l’envie de pénis à l’envie de pénal’.
Admirez, là encore, la délicatesse du jeu de mot !
Quant à Tariq Ramadan il parle de lui, page 147/148/149,
avec une grande sympathie,
racontant leurs échanges autour d'un repas joyeux
qu’il a partagé avec lui le 4 janvier 2012 dans un restaurant asiatique,
en présence d'Éric Naulleau.
Il dit :
« A notre table l’ambiance est décontractée ;
chacun y met de sien.
Ramadan est souriant et avenant,
on évoque l’Egypte et sa famille,
l’Algérie et la mienne […]
On ne cède à rien,
mais les vapeurs de crevettes
et les soles à la sauce caramel sont avalées sous les rires…».
S’agissant des "ennuis judiciaires" de Ramadan,
Zemmour affirme :
" je demeure convaincu qu’il est tombé dans un piège.
Les jeunes femmes qui l’accusent
expliquent qu’elles ne peuvent se détacher de lui,
que son aura les fascine,
que son intelligence les ensorcelle,
qu’il en profite pour les manipuler à sa guise.
C’est cette fameuse notion ‘d’emprise’,
dernière trouvaille des féministes pour criminaliser l’homme,
bourreau éternel,
sans se rendre compte,
dans leur hargne vindicative,
que leur définition de l’emprise’ et ses effets pervers
ressemble comme une sœur
à ce qu’on appelait jadis dans les romans et les chansons populaires
les ‘affres de l’amour’."
Il explique qu’il a pris en pitié Ramadan en le voyant, à la télé,
sortir de prison
« les cheveux blanchis,
la mine défaite,
la voix cassée d’un vieillard »
et surtout lorsque Jean-Jacques Bourdin lui a demandé :
« Pratiquez-vous la sodomie, Tariq Ramadan ? ».
Ecoutez Tariq Ramadan sur le plateau de Jean -Jacques Bourdin
Au fond, Éric Zemmour est solidaire de Tariq Ramadan
parce qu'ils partagent les mêmes idées réactionnaires
et rêvent d’un même monde pétri de haine.
D’une certaine manière,
Zemmour en partie est en train de récolter
ce que Tariq Ramadan à semer pendant les dernières décennies…
Cette complicité
ne peut que nous confirmer
dans la nécessaire articulation
de la lutte contre l'idéologie obscurantiste islamiste
qui a enfanté le monstre terroriste
et du combat
contre toute forme du racisme, d'antisémitisme et de xénophobie.